- What I do is more than a manicure,
it's micro-activism.
You can be cute and multi-faceted
and vocal about your message.
(uptempo instrumental music)
My name is Ami Vega
and I'm a nail artist
out of New York City.
I became a nail artist by chance.
It was always something I did for myself,
since I was maybe 13 years old,
and I thought about it,
and I wanted to pursue it more seriously,
so I went to nail school
and got my license.
So, I work on fashion shoots,
but nail art is mostly what I do.
I think socially conscious
nail art is important
now more than ever because
of the things going on,
not just in our country
but all around the world.
Everything under Black Lives
Matter, women's rights,
LGBT rights, women's health,
domestic violence against
women is also another one.
No matter what you have on your nails,
they bring attention.
It brings your eyes to their nails.
It kind of brings the
conversation into real life.
Nowadays, we depend so
much on social media,
and it kind of just
brings that interaction
of person-to-person.
Somebody will see your
nail art and wanna inquire,
and then you have a
moment and an opportunity
to talk about that topic.
It's more than just being
cute and having cute nails,
it's having a message and
feeling strong about it,
and be vocal about it.
As a woman, sometimes we're made to be
a bit more submissive,
and this is a way of kind getting strength
in our own messages
and saying, "Hey, I am gonna be cute,
"but I also have a message to say,
"and I'm gonna wear it on my fingers,"
you know?
To be an activist means to
feel strongly about something,
whatever it may be.
More than anything,
staying true to yourself and your message.
(uptempo instrumental music)